- Does it make?
Oh yes they love this.
(squeaks)
(playful music)
2015, Party, 'cause that was a party
and my absolute favorite
song would have to be,
Into the New World 'cause
that's what started the story.
Over my Skin is for everyone
about finally being comfortable
in your own skin.
I wanted to bring all the
things I love about K-pop
and all the things I love
about the pop I grew up to
and for an album, yes,
I'm hoping to continuously
put out music and hopefully
have a body of work
to share for my fans.
There was like Fannytastics,
friends here were like,
we can call them Fannypacks.
I was like oh my god no.
But there are some really
really fun and creative names
so I'm really looking
forward to what the fans
come up with.
So, let me know what you guys think.
Don't say Fannypack.
I'm a huge fan of the Lionheart Talk Talk
because I had a lot of
input on that album.
That song, I loved so
much, that I performed
at my solo concert like
on an acoustic version.
Sorry to disappoint but,
nope, actually they
said, if she doesn't pick
the Lionheart Talk
Talk, we don't know her.
So yes, you do know me.
The tour outfit and I feel
like everybody's like yes.
That was not the pink we
thought we were getting.
And then it was like fluorescent
almost obnoxious pink.
(jazzy music)
Everything is a challenge but growing up
in front of the camera, my
band mates and I were talking
about certain things
and then they're like,
wow we coped really well
and I was like, yeah,
a pat on the back to everybody.
Growing up would probably be
one of the toughest things
but I'm here.
At this interview, I made it.
(soft music)
I feel like I'd probably
be doing the art side
or the behind the scenes side to music
or fashion or puppies or, (laughs)
I guess I'm getting both worlds
where I get to come here and
say I'm thinking in Korean
because I was always thinking in English
when I was in Korea but I
guess I'm flexing both muscles.
(playful music)
my secret is having just
as comfortable shoes
when I'm off of 'em and balancing,
'cause you can yes, it's unreal.
My choreographers unreal.
(laughs)
Mind control.
Oh my god I look so creepy saying that.
So does that make me Professor X?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- Thank you.
Call me professor T.
(soft music)
Little Mermaid is everything,
because morals and values
were built on Disney.
Being in a world where you
think you have everything
and everyone tells you that you should,
that you should believe
what they're saying
but you believe in a
bigger world and you go out
of your comfort zone for love
and I think that's an amazing story.
And it's ironic 'cause
I'm scared of fish eyes.
Weird, right?
No side eyes though from Ariel.
(upbeat music)
That's a hard question
because we love all of them.
But I did get to meet Victoria Beckham.
She told me about, she said,
yeah being in a girl band
is amazing, you create family from that.
And I was like, you're right.
I love all of you.
(laughs)
Yes, I love them all.
(playful music)
It was during their interview,
Taeyeon was like, yeah,
you need to go see her and she's like,
I'm not that desperate.
And it was a joke but
I guess the fans love
when we say like pretty intense key words
and that's why they're like,
Taeyeon's not desperate.
She posted a support post on my song.
She put like every pink emoji there was
and that takes a lot of time and heart
and then the fans are like,
yeah, totally desperate.
I was like, no she just
loves me, we love each other.
Yes, we are desperate for each other.
Does that clear everything?
(laughs)
These adorable puppies
are available for adoption
at Best Friends Animal Society,
check out their website
at bestfriends.org.
(fun music)
(whooshes and squeaks)